اذا كانت تركيا المستقره والمتقدمه دمر
فيها الزلزال المباني التي شيدت تحت اعين
الحكومه والرقابه فماذا عن سوريا التي
تعيش منذ 12 سنه ازمه خنقتها اقتصاديا
وسياسيا مسؤولون في النظام السوري اقروا
بوجود مخالفات كبيره في عمليات البناء في
سوريا كاشفين عن ان 5% فقط من الابنيه في
سوريا خضعت لشروط السلامه خلال البناء منذ
2011 بينما بقيه الابنيه غير معلومه
مواصفات مواد البناء الداخله والمستخدمه
فيها وفقا لعضو لجنه الكود السوري للبناء
عصام ملحم لاحدى الاذاعات المحليه السوريه
ماذا اوضح ملحم قال ان من ينفذ المنشات
الهندسيه في سوريا هم اما مهنيون او
مقاولون واغلب المقاولين لا يمتلكون معرفه
علميه في البناء اضافه ايضا
وجودي اي نظام هندسي او قانون يتابع اعمال
التنفيذ وانما يقتصر التدقيق على مهندس
مشرف يستلم حديد التسلف في اثناء التركيب
ما يشير لمخالفات ضخمه في البناء بسوريا
بالتالي ايضا تنبا ملحم بخسائر اكبر في
حال حدوث زلزال اخر في سوريا لماذا لان
ابنيه المخالفات في كثير من المناطق غير
سليمه انشائيا كما ان المقاولين يتركون
الابنيه على الهيكل لسنوات طويله وهي عرضه
بشكل اكبر للتاثر بالظروف المناخيه
وبالاخص في المناطق الساحليه حيث عامل
الرطوبه يؤثر على فولاذ التسليح كما يتسبب
بتاكله او صدقه